hey everybody Shaw McGinnis here with a
game guide from Miguel concepción just
like in the first forts of horizon your
car collection and horizon 2 isn't
complete unless you found all the relics
hidden throughout the game map in the
new setting of France and Italy there
are 10 vehicles to find all waiting to
be restored by making general progress
in the game you'll hear rumors of new
barn locations indicated by a
semi-transparent white circle on the map
in our playthrough the tenth barn
revealed itself when we reached level 60
some barns can take you a minute to find
while others might take you a half an
hour
our guide provides some of the most
direct routes to each bar
first start on the highway east of the
golf course and set your marker on the
road south of the speed trap at the west
point of San Giovanni when you reach the
Waypoint look for the section where the
road barrier begins then head north
about a quarter mile
[Music]
number two begin at the west point of
nice using the hint circle as a frame of
reference set the marker on the road
south of the wishbone shaped patch of
forest once you've reached the Waypoint
head north and look for a beaten path
the barn is about 1/8 of a mile north
[Music]
number three start at the west side of
the golf course near st. Martin set the
destination marker at the middle of the
road that cuts through the lower half of
the hint circle after reaching the
Waypoint head north through the rows of
trees look for a blue tractor to easily
locate the bar
[Music]
number four begin at the West outskirts
of sister on set the marker at the
southern section of the hint circle at
the T intersection once you've reached
your destination follow the beaten path
north and drive through the dried-up
river the bard can be found on the other
side of the river
[Music]
number five start at the Northwest
outskirts of Casta Leto set the Waypoint
at the upper corner of the u-shaped
paved path that runs through the hint
circle once you've reached your
destination head east and slightly north
through the small forest to find the bar
[Music]
number six begin on the road east of the
word Montelena on the map set the marker
slightly north of the cross intersection
in the hint circle where the forest
meets the fields on the map once you've
reached the Waypoint drive east look for
the large open storage area the barn is
slightly north east of that
number seven
starting at the hub and Montelena set
the waypoint at the short straightaway
that runs from north to south
inside the hint circle once you've
reached your destination head west for
about 1/8 of a mile
[Music]
number eight start at the hub in San
Giovanni set the Waypoint to the part of
the road that makes a 90-degree turn in
the middle of the hint circle when
you've reached the marker simply
continue on straight up the hill for a
couple of seconds to find the bar
[Music]
number nine begin at the south point of
San Giovanni on the three parallel roads
within the hint circle set the Waypoint
in the middle of the bottom road once
you've reached the marker head north up
the hill you'll find the bar and amongst
the various structures in this secluded
spot
[Music]
and finally number 10 this is the
easiest barn find of them all just drive
slightly south of the letter F in the
map text horizon festival
[Music]
and there you have it that's all ten of
the barn fines and forts of horizon 2 if
you have any other tips for finding
these let us know in the comments
[Music]